Before we conclude this lesson I'd like
to spend a little more time to talk
about designing experiments.
It sounds like it's easy,
we just need to run bunch of test cases,
gather the metrics,
and show the results.
Not so fast actually,
you running tests, gathering metrics and
plotting the results.
It's not as straightforward
as it might seem.
There is actually a lot of thought and
planning that should go into
designing relevant experiments.
By relevant experiment, I'm referring to
an experiment that will lead to certain
statements about a solution.
That are credible,
that others will believe in,
and that are also relevant
that they will care for.
For example, the paper we discussed
is full of relevant experiments.
There the authors provided the detailed
descriptions of each of the experiments.
So that we could understand them and
then we could believe that
those results are seen.
And then we were also able to make well
founded statements about flash and
the ambit model versus all of
the other implementations.
Let's continue talking about
the web server as an example for
which we'll try to justify what
makes some experiments relevant.
Well, the clients using the Web Server.
They care for the response time.
How quickly do they get a web page back?
The operators, for instance,
running that Web Server, that website.
We care about throughput,
how many total client requests can see
that webpage over a period of time?
So this illustrates that you will
likely need to justify your solution,
using some criteria that's
relevent to the stakeholders.
For instance, if you can show that your
solution improves both response time and
throughput, everybody is positively
impacted, so that's great.
If you can show that your solution
only improves response time but
doesn't really affect throughput,
well okay.
I'll buy that too.
It serves me some benefit.
If I see a solution that
improves response time and
actually degrades throughput,
that still could be useful.
Perhaps for this improved response time.
I can end up charging clients more that
ultimately will give me the revenue that
I'm losing due to
the negative throughput.
Or maybe I need to define
some experiments in which
I'm trying to understand how is
the response time that the client see,
how is it effected when the overload
of the Web Server increases,
when the request rate increases?
So by understanding the stakeholders and
the goals that I want to meet with
respect to these stakeholders.
I'm able to define what are some metrics
that I need to pay attention to.
And that will give me insight
into useful configurations of
the experiments.
When you're picking metrics,
a rule of thumb should be,
what are some of the standard metrics
that are popular in the target domain?
For instance, for Web Servers, it makes
sense to talk about the client request
rate or the client response time.
This will let you have
a broader audience.
More people will be able to understand
the results and to relate to them,
even if those particular results
don't give you the best punchline.
Then you absolutely have to include
metrics that really provide answers to
questions such as,
why am I doing this work?
What is it that I want to improve or
understand by doing these experiments?
Who is it that cares for this?
Answering these questions implies
what are the metrics that you need to
keep track of.
For instance, if you're
interested in client performance.
Probably the things that you need to
keep track of are things like response
time, or
number of requests that have timed out.
Or if you're interested in
improving the operator costs,
then you worry about things like
throughput, or power costs, and similar.
Once you understand
the relevant metrics,
you need to think about the system
factors that affect those metrics.
One aspect will be things
like system resources.
This will include hardware
resources such as the number and
type of CPUs or amount of memory that's
available on the server machines, and
also the software specific resources
like number of threads or the size
of certain queues or buffer structures
that are available in the program.
Then there are a number of configuration
parameters that define the workload.
Things that make sense for Web Server
include the request rate, the file size,
the access pattern, things that were
varied also in the flesh experiments.
And now that you understand the
configuration space a little bit better,
make some choices.
Choose a subset of the configuration
parameters that probably are most
impactful when it comes to changes in
the metrics that you're observing.
Pick some ranges for
these variable parameters.
These ranges must also be relevent.
Don't show that your server runs well
with one, two, and three threads, so
don't vary the number of threads
in your server configuration.
If you look out and then you see
that real world deployments,
they have servers with thread
counts in the hundreds.
Or don't go and vary the file sizes.
To have sizes of 10000 and
one kilobytes.
If you look at what's happening in
the real world, file sizes range
from maybe from tens of bytes
up to tens of megabytes and
hundreds of megabytes and beyond.
So make sure that the ranges
are representative of reality.
Again, these ranges must somehow
correspond to some realistic scenario
that's relevant.
Otherwise, nobody will care for
your hypothetical results.
That is,
unless your hypothetical results
are concerned with demonstrating
the best or the worst case scenarios.
Best and worst case scenarios
do bring some value, because.
They, in a way they demonstrate
certain limitations, or
certain opportunities that are there,
because of the system that you've
proposed, because of
the solution you have proposed.
So these are the only times where
picking a non realistic workload
makes sense.
Like for instance,
in the flash paper case.
They had an example in which every
single one of the requests was accessing
one, single file.
And there was some value in
the results that were obtained
through that experiment.
For the various factors
that you're considering,
pick some useful combinations.
There will be a lot of
experiments where the results
simply reiterate the same point.
It really doesn't make sense
to make endless such results.
Few are good, it's good to confirm
that some observation is valid, but
including tens of them it
really doesn't make any sense.
A very important point,
compare apples to apples.
For instance let's look
at one bad example.
We have one combination in which we run
an experiment with a large workload.
And a small size of resources.
And then a second experiment,
second run of the experiment in
which we've changed the workload so
now we have a small workload and then
we have also allocated more resources.
So, for instance, more threads.
And then we look at these results and
we see that In the second case,
for the second experimental run.
The performance is better, so
then we may draw a conclusion,
well I've increased the resource size,
it added more threads.
And therefore, my performance
has improved, so I must be
able to conclude that performance
improves when I increase the resources.
That's clearly wrong, I have no idea
whether performance improved because
I've added more resources.
Or because I have changed the workload.
So, I'm using a much smaller
workload in the second case.
This is what we mean by, make sure that
you're comparing apples to apples.
There's no way you can draw a conclusion
between these two experiments.
And what about the competition.
What is the baseline for
the system that you're evaluating?
You should think about experiments
that are able to demonstrate
that the system you're designing,
the solution you're proposing, in some
way improves the state of the art.
Otherwise it's not clear why use yours.
And if it's not really
the state-of-the-art then at least
what's the most common practice,
that should be improved.
And perhaps there's some other
benefits over the state-of-the-art
that are valuable.
Or at least think about evaluating
your system by comparing with some
extreme conditions in terms of
the workload or resource assignment,
so some of the best or
worst case scenarios.
That will provide insight into
some properties of your solution.
Like, how does it scale as
the workload increases, for instance.